Y si tu cerebro está fallando
al integrar malas noticias sobre el futuro,
llevarás puestas constantemente tus gafas de color de rosa.
Queríamos saber, ¿podremos cambiar esto?
¿Podremos alterar el optimismo de la gente
interfiriendo en la actividad cerebral de estas regiones?
Hay una manera de hacerlo.
Este es mi colaborador Ryota Kanai.
Y lo que está haciendo es pasar un pequeño pulso magnético
a través del cráneo del participante en el estudio
hacia su circunvolución frontal inferior.
Y haciendo esto,
está interfiriendo en la actividad de esta región del cerebro
durante aproximadamente media hora.
Después de esto todo vuelve a la normalidad, se los aseguro.
(Risas)
Veamos qué sucede.
Primero que nada, voy a mostrarles
la cantidad media de predisposición que encontramos.
Si fuera a examinarles a todos Uds. ahora,
esta es la cantidad que aprenderían
más de las buenas noticias comparado con las malas.
Ahora interferimos con la región
que averiguamos que integra información negativa,
y la predisposición al optimismo se hace incluso mayor.
Hacemos que la gente esté más predispuesta en el sentido en el que procesan la información.
Entonces interferimos en la región cerebral
que encontramos que integra buenas noticias,
y la predisposición al optimismo desapareció.
Estábamos asombrados con estos resultados
porque fuimos capaces de eliminar
una predisposición profundamente arraigada en los humanos.
Y llegados a este punto, paramos y nos preguntamos,
¿querríamos destrozar en pedacitos la ilusión del optimismo?
Si podemos hacerlo, ¿querríamos quitarle a la gente la predisposición al optimismo?
Bien, ya les he hablado de todos los beneficios que tiene la predisposición al optimismo,
la cual probablemente haga quieran aferrarse a ella desesperadamente.
Pero por supuesto existen inconvenientes
y sería realmente estúpido de nuestra parte, ignorarlos.
Tomemos como ejemplo este e-mail que he recibido
de un bombero aquí en California.
Dice, "Investigaciones con bomberos sobre casos con víctimas mortales
normalmente incluyen 'No pensamos que el fuego fuera a hacer eso'
incluso cuando toda la información disponible
estuviese allí para tomar decisiones seguras".
Este capitán va a emplear nuestros hallazgos acerca de la predisposición al optimismo
para intentar explicar a los bomberos
por qué piensan de la manera en que lo hacen,
con el fin de hacerles del todo conscientes sobre la predisposición al optimismo de la gente.
Es que el optimismo no realista puede llevar a un comportamiento peligroso;
al colapso financiero, a una planificación deficiente.
El gobierno británico, por ejemplo,
ha reconocido que la predisposición al optimismo
puede hacer que los individuos sean más propensos
a subestimar el coste y la duración de los proyectos.
Así que han ajustado el presupuesto de las Olimpiadas del 2012
teniendo en cuenta la predisposición al optimismo.
Mi amigo que se casa dentro de unas semanas
ha hecho lo mismo con su presupuesto para la boda.
Y por cierto, cuando le pregunté sobre de sus posibilidades de divorciarse,
dijo que estaba seguro de que eran del 0%.
Lo que quisiéramos hacer,
es protegernos a nosotros mismos de los peligros del optimismo,
pero al mismo tiempo mantener la esperanza,
beneficiándonos de los muchos frutos del optimismo.
Y creo que hay una manera de hacerlo.
La clave aquí es el conocimiento.
No nacemos con un entendimiento innato de nuestras predisposiciones.
Deben ser identificadas a través de la investigación científica.
Pero la buena noticia es que ser consciente de la predisposición al optimismo
no destruye la ilusión.
Es como las ilusiones visuales,
en las que entenderlas no las hace desaparecer.
Y esto es bueno porque significa
que podríamos encontrar un equilibrio,
cumplir los planes y las reglas
para protegernos del optimismo no realista,
pero al mismo tiempo permanecer esperanzados.
Creo que este dibujo lo refleja bien.
Ya que si eres uno de los pingüinos pesimistas de allá arriba
que simplemente creen que no pueden volar,
ciertamente nunca lo harás.
Porque para hacer cualquier tipo de progreso,
necesitamos ser capaces de imaginar una realidad diferente,
y además necesitamos creer que esa realidad es posible.
Pero si uno es un pingüino con un optimismo extremo
que salta ciegamente al vacío esperando lo mejor,
puede encontrar un pequeño desastre cuando llegue al suelo.
Pero si uno es un pingüino optimista
que cree que puede volar,
pero que se pone un paracaídas en la espalda
por si las cosas no van exactamente como las ha planeado,
volará como un águila,
incluso si uno es sólo un pingüino.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)